every time I hear somebody take Walker
do you want him to walk
he is from Long Beach California ladies
and gentlemen put your hands together
for hey guys yes it's going down baby
tacos on todo
that's tacos with everything if you
don't speak Spanish Google that [ __ ]
people my grad at Google or trapped
after this shit's good I'm gonna tackle
with uncle Joey bro what's going on here
is every time I've bombed on stage you
want to order anything I don't know what
the [ __ ] we're doing prep me or [ __ ]
I don't think I was so acquainted with
these up into like a bang bus that's a
different online show where is the
[ __ ] food what are you doing to me
am I being Punk'd on this [ __ ] show
come on these dudes earn them tacos baby
recognize me now
hello whether you feel lonely Spanish
why hola the stand-up comics are really
like the modern-day philosophers the
plazas not the comedy club relationships
free time privacy it's all been given up
for the sake of that stage I remember
used to say this a lot when we're on the
road is like you can't choose comedy
comedy chooses you mm-hmm that's real
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter tacos tacos
bro hey Suz Trejo is in the building
tacos con todo a new show on first we
feast Tuesdays at 11 a.m. this is the
initiation a last dab taco oh yeah hey
Suz Trejo
welcome to the family mom thanks ma'am
this is gonna hurt tomorrow